نحن نتواجد الان اقصى شمال بيت لاهيا
بالتحديد في المنطقه الزراعيه هنا كانت
تتواجد قوات الاحتلال والياته في هذه
المنطقه حيث قامت بتدمير جميع الاراضي
الزراعيه هنا في بيت لاهيا حيث ان بيت
لاهيا تشكل النسبه الاكبر من المحصول
الزراعي على مستوى قطاع غزه كما نشاهد هنا
حجم هذا الدمار في هذه المناطق نتيجه توغل
قوات الاحتلال في هذه المنطقه حيث قامت
بتدمير الاراضي الزراعيه طبعا معنا الان
رئيس بلديه بيت لاهيه ليحدثنا عن الوضع
نتيجه تدمير قوات الاحتلال لهذه الاراضي
هنا في بيت لاهيا تعتبر بيت لاهيا مدينه
بيت لاهيا التي تغذي القطاع وهي السله
الاولى على مستوى قطاع غزه وتمد سكان قطاع
غزه بالاحتياجات من الخضروات والمحاصيل
الموسم على طول العام فوجدنا تدمير كامل
للقطاع الزراعي في هذه المنطقه حيث دمر
العدو ما يزيد عن 20,000 دولم من المحاصيل
الزراعيه ونذكر نخص بالذكر منها محاصيل
البطاطا والبندوره والجزر والخس وايضا
محصول الفراوله محصول الفراوله الذهب
الاحمر الذي يقوم المزارعين في شمال غزه
في مدينه بيتلا بتصديره الى دول اوروبا
والى دول الخليج هنا فقدنا هذا العام كل
هذه المحاصيل هناك ما يزيد عن 1250 ال طير
من الدجاج اللاحم ودجاج البياض تم تدمير
هذه المزارع التي يقوم المزارعين بتربيه
هذه الدواجن فيها وايضا تدمير مزارع
الابقار وثلاجات حفظ الخضار والفواكه يعني
عننا ايضا قام العدو بتدمير الابار
والطاقه الشمسيه التي يعتمد عليها
المزارعين بشكل اساسي وايضا تدمير
معظم الادوات الزراعيه والبذور طبعا اقل
مزارع اقل مزارع عنده اضرار ب 200000
دولار وما فوق ديون عليه غير الاراضي
الزراعيه اللي كان هو صاحبها يعني اكبر من
نكبه اكبر من نكبه حتى ه المنطقه صارت غير
صالحه لاي نوع من الحياه فش لا سكن ولا
حياه ولا ميه ولا اي حاجه يصلح انه البني
ادم يعيش فيها واي حتى اي حاجه على وجه
الارض تعيش فيها نحن في مجاعه حقيقيه في
قطاع غزه ف نناشد كل دول العالم واحرار
العالم بتدخل السريع لانقاذ ما تبقى من
غزه وادخال المعدات للمزارعين وادخال
الابار للمزارعين وادخال الطاقه الشمسيه
والسولار اللازم والبذور اللازمه
لاحياء القطاع الزراعي من
جديد اذا هذا ما فعله الاحتلال بالثروه
الحيوانيه والثروه الزراعيه نتيجه هذا
التوغل هنا في بيت لاهيه لم يوجد اي مكان
الان هنا صالح للزراعه نتيجه هذا التوغل
وهذا الدمار الذي خلفته قوات
الاحتلال انس الشريف الجزيره شمال غزه